hello everyone and welcome to everyone's
favorite tournament
is the final game of the pogchamps three
championship
uh and um this is the blitz game so the
in the park champs usually they play
uh in rapid time form it's 10 minutes
per player but as
uh the two rapid games ended in the draw
first was won by
uh rain wilson second one by sardosha uh
this is now the
the tiebreaker and this is a blitz game
quite a short one and quite a deadly one
uh we didn't cover all that many games
but i did say i will
show the the game from the finals so
uh without further ado let's check it
out it's uh uh rayne wilson uh
uh a producer uh actor rider you've seen
him in pretty much everything now also
in the park champs
uh facing a mid laner uh for the french
league of legends team i cannot
pronounce that really but it's something
like uh le frede purgatoria
uh i always butcher french names uh but
yeah it's it's quite a game uh so
so let's check it out uh uh wilson with
the white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have c5 sorry about
that
uh the sicilian defense is on the board
we have knight to f3
and e6 now uh we have b3
and this is a very uh tricky variation
it's been played by hickey vesterin and
a finnish grandmaster who often employed
this
and uh due to this it carries his name
uh but usually you'll see something like
d4 here maybe knight to c3
b3 is uh well very rare
uh but okay preparing to fianchetto the
the dark square bishop and now here
black might do the same black might play
b6 bishop to b7 now but here sardosha
goes
knights to c6 he wants to strike in the
center right away
we have bishop to b2 and now d5 striking
in the center and this is all perfectly
fine for both sides
uh we have uh captures um uh sorry e
captures on e5 e captures on d5
and now bishop to e2 you could go a bit
uh deeper into the position bishop to b5
it's a kind of a general ruling just to
develop your pieces as deep into your
opponent's position as possible
but here it's um uh you you kind of have
to ask yourself
what if black plays a6 do i capture do i
go back point is here
it's fine to capture here because after
lasik captures captures and castles
black still needs to develop both bishop
and the knight to be able to castle and
white already
is ready to go for some sort of an
attack so maybe it would be
uh and not not so great for black to
play a6 so bishop to b5 definitely
possible
uh rain ring goes for bishop to e2
instead
we have knight to f6 and now castles uh
we have bishop to e7 black is now also
ready to castle
and now you might try a lot of things
here d4 is a known move here in this
position and in all of the games that
actually reached this position so far
i think there were four or five of them
from uh official tournaments uh
in all of them d4 was played but here we
have h3 by rain and
it is as of move eight that we have a
completely new game
so let's see what happens uh we have
castles by black and now
bishop to b5 and here you see that the
bishop never really had
anything to do on e2 because uh you
don't really need
the both h3 move and bishop to e2 you
don't really care about bishop g4 since
your bishop is already on e2
so playing both bishop e2 and h3 are not
really
not really the well there's no point in
doing that so here bishop to b5 now
getting the bishop to uh where it should
have been with bishop to d7
and rook to e1 getting the rook to the
nice open e file
rook 38 black prepared prepares to
counter white's rook and now
knight to c3 so what do you play here
here you might uh
you might go d4 and the position is
basically screaming for d4 but here
black first goes for a6 challenges white
slide square bishop
we have bishop captures on c6 bishop
captures in c6 and now uh
uh rain goes for d4 saying that now
uh he he will not allow black to push d4
and he is very very happy with his
position but now black
goes b5 probably with the idea of
dislodging this knight would be four
but okay uh here you could go for
captures and captures and let's say you
trade everything off captures capture 78
but still you're white and you don't
really have anything to show for
black has a very very strong bishop pair
he's going to play the rook the c8 or d8
both are possible you can either support
this spawn or as you're controlling the
c4 square you can even play rook to c8
hold down on that c2 pawn which is a
backward spawn so
a lot of a lot of possible ideas here
for uh
for black so not really uh interested in
doing that
uh he instead goes uh uh knight to e2
and now the knight can come to g3 from
g3 the knight can come
to f5 and he wants to shift his attack
over to the king side then the g7 pawn
might become weak uh the bishop will
also help out
so that's kind of the plan we have c for
now c4 is one of those
weird moves that um are actually
playable because you want to keep this
dark square bishop closed you do not
want to allow white to capture this and
open up this diagonal so
c4 definitely makes sense here we have
knight to f4
abandoning the plan of going knight to
g3 and to f5 so knight to f4 instead
uh and now comes bishop to d6 putting
pressure on the knight here
so queen to d2 defending that knight on
f4 also connecting rooks this is
something you always want to do to
finish development
and black needs to do the same and black
does it with tempo queen to c7
and now the rooks are connected and the
knight on f4 is under attack although
here knight to e4 was also incredibly
strong it's a beautiful square for the
knight attacks the queen on d2
so this was definitely the way to go but
okay queen to c7 first putting pressure
on the knight here
and now knight to e5 and this is now a
monster knight here nothing can dislodge
it
it's very well defended by the pawn by
the rook by the bishop on b2
but here black finds a most unpleasant
move and that is
knight to e4 now the queen is under
attack and here you have a problem uh
because the knight moved
from f6 to e4 the f6 square has been
vacated for the pawn and this is
sadoshi's plan
we have queen to e3 and now the absolute
best move for black
is f6 and this is what is played f6 and
now if you move the knight then of
course the bishop
the knight on f4 hangs so knight
captures on c6 was played and here
uh black actually recaptured on c6
however
bishop captures was the way to go it
seems uh like
it's just the same because after let's
say queen f3 uh
if you capture the knight then the
bishop falls as well problem for white
is that black has this bishop to d2 move
attacking in the rook and now you have
to decide you're
either gonna try and save the rook with
something like rookie two then
black wins the knight on c6 then black
is up a piece and black is completely
winning
so instead of going for this we have
queen captures on c6 and now
uh white is still uh white is still able
to keep on fighting white plays queen to
f3 now probably with ideas of
just getting the queen out of the e file
from the rook and maybe also shifting
the queen to the attack
uh but here again you can play c3 you
can close off this
uh like dark square bishop completely
or you can go queen to c7 is what uh
sardoche played he goes after this uh
knight on f4 so the knight is under
attack twice
and here uh we have a really really
awesome move by white and that is
knight captures on d5 it's a very strong
move it attacks the queen here also
removes the defender of the knight so
the knight can now be captured
but here is uh where things start to go
wrong here
white uh has some minute one minute on
the clock whereas black has three
minutes on the clock
and here we reach the position from the
thumbnail bishop to h2 check was played
now one move uh wins the game for white
one move loses the game for white so
feel free to pause the video what would
you play here while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not playing king to f1 and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show yes
king the h1 is the way to go however
in the game uh king the f1 was played
and here uh sardochi just played uh
knight to d2 and this is not only a
royal fork as it
uh now checks the king and grabs the
queen but also it is
checkmate because the bishop covers the
g1 squared the rook cuts off the king's
uh
uh path to the e2 square so you don't
have any moves all of the squares are
blocked and your king is in check this
is this is checkmate
uh if if uh if if
rain wilson played something other than
king to f1 which is the only other legal
move and that is king to h1
here black really has no moves and he
had a one more minute on the clock i
think this was just uh
i think he knew that he was kind of
winning here and
he thought he was all the same i guess
he missed knight to d
to check uh and he thought okay wherever
i go it's just a completely winning game
but here
uh after king to h1 it would indeed be
winning because this is now attacked
twice
uh the queen is under attack if the
queen moves from this diagonal also the
bishop can be captured
and there just isn't a good move here
once you move the queen let's say queen
to f7
now you just start gobbling up material
rook captures here now the bishop is
being threatened
the knight of course cannot be captured
if you capture the knight and this just
comes away to check
so after you captured the defender of
the queen has been removed
just queen capture sun and d5 with check
and this is now completely winning for
white
uh so yeah after this uh knight to d2
checkmate the game was over and
the entire tournament goes to andreas
hornet
also known as sardosha and he is the
winner of the
pogchamps 3 tournament so really really
crazy game
uh and it's very interesting i've seen
some games uh from pogchamps one
also pogchamps too and now uh in the
finals of boxing
three th the games are of uh much much
of a much higher quality so we'll see
when it comes to the pogchamps standpok
champs 20 boxing 30
uh we will probably have some 23 24
maybe even 2 500 players who are
who are not even chess players but uh
you know chess will be
so uh into everyone's uh lives that
you know whatever you'll be doing
whether you're a lumberjack or maybe you
know you
you attend a bar you will also be a 2500
player i mean why not
uh so now once again that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh
nice game by both of them i would like
to thank aleppo and paul 11 daniella
taylor alexander john austin and eric
berman for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day